I yeah when I when I started I thought
maybe they were winging it you know you
know they hadn't like with lost when
people kind of lost it I lost it was
like that sense that they don't know
where they're going with this they're
just doing stuff yeah it felt a lot a
lot like that then it came together and
I did enjoy yes so you watched love yeah
I can't you know I guess for its time it
was a pretty great show it was grateful
the beginning was watching it now why
try to watch it with you and I did you
could you get through it know what's
wrong with it now because of I think you
know because of handmaidens tail and
because the game of Thrones and all
these other things that were like
watching it just it looks cookie cutter
mmm good it's network TV and at the time
like network television especially like
primetime loss was revolutionary yeah it
was that [ __ ] pilot is filmed like a
film with the plane crash when he's
running through the [ __ ] forest all
scared and and the effects it were
[ __ ] mind-blowing yeah with the plane
carnage and all that and people running
around it was crazy
but I feel like what was great about
that show those there was really
charismatic actors there was really
strong characters in that show the
blonde dude and the other due to that or
I was like out you know yeah yeah yeah
yeah I'm dressed and then the the guy
who's in the hobbit who's married to the
actress that was in lost a Charlie on
the show yeah yeah yeah Dominic Dominic
Dominic gay yeah like really strong
right and hack right unlock but
Dominic's also character a shooting
heroin in the bathroom while the plane
went down right was like very edgy for
television and Daniel Dae Kim being a
very like a much he smell kind of Korean
husband yes and I wish so that dude
that's a good point because in terms of
Koreans that was the closest I've ever
seen an American like an
english-speaking film or television show
where I went that seems like a real
Korean dude he spoke Korean in it I know
but it's even his his attitude and his
the way he talked to his wife was so
Korean it would be one of those things
if I was an American producer I'd be
like it's too harsh man you know when
Koreans would be like no that's exactly
how he talks right so yeah you're right
I mean that but that show when they went
to the 70s remain if they did
time-traveling in the fifth season he
did a whole year at this end where they
did it in the time-travel I do not
remember because those people yeah yeah
okay yeah I'd love to show how do you
watch Game of Thrones I do not okay got
it
why not I thought about that I know you
guys are big fans and I've seen from
social media that some you know [ __ ] is
poppin off right now it's a big deal but
it's just it just resumed and there's
been a few episodes and everybody's
loving it yeah yeah I mean I love sci-fi
and I but III like it's in there I have
no problem with dragons I just don't
give a [ __ ] about Game of Thrones
there's there's nothing to the from the
outside that I've seen that Joss me out
like I don't care I don't care about and
I'm gonna no one's gonna relate to that
I suppose I was
it's I feel like it shouldn't be as bad
as if I said I watched two episodes and
I said [ __ ] that like I've never seen it
he's just I've never had the inclination
to check it out it's not that I checked
it out and didn't like it's funny that
you saying that Paul because no it's
just funny that you say that because um
I had dinner with a comedian my friend
Johnny Sanchez he said the same exact
thing he was a little bit more like you
know assholey about it it's a hype thing
man say I don't like fantasy bro and
it's okay I don't like I've missed a
train like [ __ ] it who gives a [ __ ] that
kind of mentality and I'm like the cool
relaxed right you were very calm about
and I get we were saying okay and I get
what you're saying
and the [ __ ] no but I get we're saying
but see here's the thing
no you said you saw two seasons of that
Star Trek Ryan the rocks I know that I
know you can start all right the wrong
Star Trek right Yeah right it has no gas
redeeming element the other sure they do
know John Luke hey Paul yeah I'm sure
they do
okay you saw probably four seasons of
loss these are the things that I know
about you right now okay
I just want to let you know fYI that's
what the kids are saying lately right
well you're in for free yeah yeah thank
you
okay it is that this show exceeds them
it's it's almost as though different art
forms the way that I've heard and I and
I do I get on the bandwagon eventually
like I watched you know The Sopranos I
watched Breaking Bad
I watched the wire I was actually early
I was I was early on in the wire army to
like anything Breaking Bad was one where
it had ended when I watched it and it
was just like everyone's saying this is
the [ __ ] business I'm gonna check out
the show and then I loved it I hear the
same things about Game of Thrones and I
trust that everyone around me is not
wrong I trust that it's actually really
great yeah but because I suppose that's
like an investment like now I'm gonna
I'm gonna have to eventually watch like
all of it and that's a whole thing for
me so why it's almost similar to why I
don't like pay attention to professional
sports or anything because it's like or
video games for me I'm aware that it
could be so deep and consume me to like
to really participate in it is going to
be this whole time commitment that I
don't have to spare why I think if you
were to catch up now at 70 hours total
that is I you know what that's it good
answer a great [ __ ] good I think that
was a [ __ ] good answer right and I've
never heard anyone say it like that it
might being - no thank you and I've
never heard anyone that was very clear
you know you're a busy guy
you have different projects you're
working on but you did watch you had
time to watch it's the raw Star Trek so
the who seats
seasons of it so I mean might say you
really struck me when you said that it
like changed your life I gotta see that
ha ha ha I forgot which podcast so I
couldn't go back and check but Paul it's
also when I say it changed my life right
that doesn't necessarily mean that you
have to go watch it I'm interested I
love sci-fi I okay good and I grew up I
actually in high school I was watching
next-generation while it was airing oh
let's go watch whatever very similar
very many waves did you remember the one
where they like go into some plane where
the organisms like only visible in 2d so
they have no idea why they're like
locked in this yeah yeah it was a very
good one yeah
[Music]